indovinate chi è mio zio tra questi
e lui mio zio ciao zio dopo che c'è
salvatore che ha oramai level abbiamo
una macchina grossa è quella cosa
facciamo
è una guerra la cucina
la fortuna del principiante
no dai
mi sono allenato in aereo
chiede vi fa non so signorino deve
vincerla ma è una cascata quali si
sposano
anche qui però non c'è colonnetta però
prende mai mai mai mai capaci capo chino
e mai zio mai zio perché me it's gone
fun cool cesta mio zio forse andiamo
allo zoo perché il mio zio mi ha
promesso che mi importa allo zoo non se
n'è mai andata all'estero
la differenza che hanno infastidito
i locali del genere rispetto all'italia
è questa
però
la vita è bella ciao antonio andò end o
vai a anno ragazzo sta quello anno
ragazzo vai da maria maria apre la botta
maria siamo tutti qui completamente a
caso non sapevo fosse così figo larghe
roba e bellissimi quasi romantico
preferire il canton yo fosse una bella
[ __ ] da poter limonare in tutta
tranquillità però non si può fare perché
antonio alla barba se la farm e che non
è quello vorrei avere del pane da
lanciare ma se avessi le panne e melo
mangiare io perché ho fame ma zio non
era questo lo zoo non sono animali veri
sono finché magia dove mai portato il
bambino che tristissimo perché le
tartarughe stanno ferme e c'è anche
ragione perché non è io ho pagato e non
mi va a vedere tartarughe che gli
chiedono se vuoi andare a visitare le
galapagos ci sono i pro ei contro e poi
sotto ti chiedono vuoi visitarle sì o no
in base a cosa clicchi c'è il contatore
che dice quanti clicca fatto il problema
che si non funziona quindi tutti quanti
no c'è un calo di turismo alle galapagos
che fa veramente paura
e bello zero garcia che mi ha portato a
questo gioco
ecco quella giornata che volevo passare
mio caro zio se tu hai visto harry
potter sai cosa devi fare con questo
serpente con questa teca
purtroppo
mai e che è ovviamente dei gorilla non
c'è traccia quasi fare parecchio
rassicurante grazie avermelo detto
comunque io sono magro manco come
stuzzicadenti pratica si inculano
l'unico vero animale che siamo riusciti
a vedere qua e questo scoiattolo che
beatamente uscito da questo bidone della
spazzatura alla ragazza scelta miji che
sta facendo tipo tipo il titanic prima
io vi giuro su dio che l'acqua era tipo
dieci metri più bassa
e siccome sta piovendo ininterrottamente
da 12 ore praticamente sia innalzato il
livello dell'acqua talmente tanto che ha
sommerso è più sporco diaz ha sommerso
le piattaforme e secondo me tra un po
anneghiamo tutti quanti però va bene e
comunque fighissima starò un po unica go
addosso però meno male che so nuotare e
nulla stiamo andando in giro io lo zio
giorgi antonio salute antonio ciao
fantastico ragazzi fattura live 25
minuti fa nella quale sono uscito
dall'hotel sono andato a di bene poi
sono tornato nella live ha detto
sicuramente adesso che faccio vedere
dove sono la gente arriva e chiede di
mercy convinto proprio tempo 20 minuti e
sta lettera è sotto la porta
allora il suo studi fa ricette pareva
che i ragazzi sono solo non eran fino a
domani
sto cercando di sopravvivere perché non
sono mai stato la solenne
città da quando sono da solo mia madre
mi ha chiesto se ho già mangiato e io le
ho risposto esattamente così
allora ragazzi mi sono rifugiato in un
ristorante coreano
mi hanno portato questo che no no no no
non ho proprio idea di che cosa cazzo
sia per tempo i danni non c'è neanche la
tovaglietta cioè la mangi qua
direttamente non sport te pareva
volevi guardano non ci avevo tutti
quando proprio neanche mezzo dubbio che
sarebbe successo
non so se avete capito che per un
voltato l'angolo questo e ho visto e ho
visto questo io io io ho visto questo
questa cosa o vivo visto questa cosa
quando ho voltato l'angolo
se sapevo portato il sacco a pelo e
dormivo qua qua questo punto sono
commosso commosso veramente che la prima
volta nella mia vita che da starbucks
non scrivono una stronzata al povero il
mio nome la prima la prima per il giuro
su dio che verrai non è mai successo
sono felice di annunciarvi che non sono
più da solo a london perchè ho invitato
la family che sta tutta lì ciao family
arca e va pensiero stava meglio prima
modelli per le [ __ ] viva viva la paz
era viva viva la passera sono riusciti
in compenso a sbagliare il nome di mio
padre mettendo sergio sergei o con la j
papi gay dove fa pjt scappa e mamma
questa roba ho sempre visto nei film pur
cacciava cosa la bambina è uscita dall
acquario che cazzo sta facendo premier
signora la bambina sta andando dentro la
quale fanno pescata sì ma perché quando
è appena uscito il video di fa vj li
dovrebbe essere il video non farlo maio
lui non va capito
non va capito tanto ghiaccio finto
un viaggio lo pinto
[Musica]
ciao bello ci dovrei prendere ti
arrampichi a un cazzo
volevi ma scusami caduta e mi spiace è
caduta il frontalino sei scemo è caduta
anche dagli adulti e mi è scaduta scusa
schulman immerge mandando le noccioline
agli scoiattoli il problema è che io
chiamo fatto colazione
quindi tipo ho mangiato metà delle
noccioline che erano per gli scoiattoli
che in pieni pieni
ciao un cazzo
dico grazie per le views grazie per caso
e tu sei bruttissimo
porcaccia [ __ ] questa è una mostra di
coccole e mano è da mt st mano cagasotto
bauscia aperitivino in centro nella
parata di tirino con la betti in centro
a me fa una fatica che arriva le [ __ ]
sui feriti
stiamo per entrare siamo tutti troppo
contenti fai vedere la tua faccia
contenta
questa è l'entrata c'è di ge compriamo
ci sono gli scacchi dei maghi gli
scacchi dei maghi ma scherzi gioco ora
ne compriamo compriamo ci sono le
cioccorane ci sono le cioccorane e dopo
di che ci sono le cioccorane la cosa più
bella di tutte della super mostrare e
sono questi i calzini dei mangiamorte
questo lo compro questo lo compro quella
la compra e miano ti aggrada tocchi
brutto stronzo
matt o quanto figo quanto cazzo può
costare una scopa vera
e stato un modo per portarlo in italia
sai com'è
ok ragazzi allora questo pezzo velo blog
perché merita un sacco allora siamo
parimenti all'interno del set c'è
praticamente qua ci sono tutte le cose
tutte le parti dove hanno girato il film
tipo questa è la sala comune dei
grifondoro dunque la vera dove hanno
girato le riprese c'è questa parte che
bellissima che l'ufficio di silente dove
c'è innanzi tutto questo che lascia
ascensore prima di entrare nell'ufficio
e questo questo coso figo bello e
dopodiché c'è l'ufficio di silente
direttamente porca [ __ ]
porca [ __ ] porca
voldemort puzza è bello di loro potente
da un bel tocco di virilità tutto questo
si mettono vicino e fanno e dicono su
fece la tipa che clicca e la scopa sale
pensa che palle cliccare sempre quel
tasto ogni persona che passa
chance non funziona un cazzo non si apre
la porta di casa così porca eva ma
secondo voi visto che sono passati 10
anni dalla camera dei segreti ma quella
cazzo di pentola non è ancora pulita
ancora che gira dio dio dio dio bono
buon dio siamo per salire in questo
preciso momento sul binario 9 e 3 quarti
è la prima volta che mi capita
un'emozione leggere parti quando sono
nato
anche lì ero contento ma sono più
contento
vieni mondo
madonna quanti stretta sa cosa cazzo
facendo io son magro centro attento
figurativo non può peso stiamo facendo
un break tra l'altro qua fuori c'è il
ponte quello di hogwarts niente ci sta
messa e mangiare perché ci abbiamo una
fame pazzesca e ho preso questo da
mangiare davano solo e soltanto
burrobirra facciamo questo testo
assaggiamo una indiretta ti faccio
sapere come se fa veramente cagare o se
merita ma dopo la burrobirra
ma di burro
con un tipo di birra comportato la
famiglia al suo uscite per chi di voi
non è mai stato sushi si mangia così ai
farmaci vedere come sei bravo ma ai papà
bravissimo ma bravo hai finito tutto ne
vuoi ancora papa tavola fa bravo papà
nova
sfiga che adesso sono su instagram ecco
tutte le sfighe andiamo facile aperitivo
in centro